Imagine that person x signs a contract
with person y whereby x agrees to pay.
Why $10,000 and why agrees to shoot person
z if the parties failed to carry out
their promises,
you probably feel that
as an intuitive matter,
no court would enforce the party's
agreement in order damages for breach of
contract. That intuition
is correct, but why?
One important reason is because of the
negative externalities of the agreement
with regard to person Z.
I've said in the past that the formation
defenses can be seen as policing the
revealed preference inference to make
sure that the contract is value enhancing.
Formation defenses tend to render
contracts voidable when courts aren't
confident that the agreement really
is in the party's joint interest,
but illegality doctrine sets aside
contracts when the agreement may not be
welfare enhancing because of net
negative effects on people outside the
contract.
The illegality defense can thus set aside
contracts even when there is no defect
in the bargaining process.
Even if the parties manifests sufficient
ascent courts can set aside the
agreement if one of the promises exchanged
is illegal or violates public policy.
As we will see,
the circumstances in which questions of
illegality or public policy arise are
often much less clear cut than
the hired shooting example.
Above determining when an agreement is
illegal shouldn't prove too difficult,
but how should a court determine if
an agreement violates public policy?
To take one example,
consider a class of agreements known
as Allie [inaudible] contracts.
Aliya Tory comes from the Latin word for
die and Alia Tory promise is a promise,
the performance of which depends on
the occurrence of some fortuitous event
occurring.
Perhaps the most common example of of
of Aliya Tory promises are found in
insurance contracts.
If you have fire insurance,
your insurer does not
have to pay unless you,
unless and until your property burns.
Generally these agreements
are enforceable,
but common law has long viewed
gambling as against public policy.
The line between enforceable Aliya Tory
agreements and unenforceable wagers can
become blurry indeed.
Why does public policy prohibit
the ladder but not the former?
One possible explanation,
at least for these examples is that
buying insurance is usually a responsible
risk.
Mitigating decision.
Gambling by contracts
creates artificial risk.
Problem often hurts the
gambler's loved ones.
While we don't even have the
category of problem ensuring
historically courts typically took a
hard line against enforcing illegal
contracts according to the
first restatement of contracts
and it's section five
12 a bargain is illegal within the
meaning of the restatement if either it's
formation or its performance is criminal
tortious or otherwise opposed to public
policy.
As the comments to this section make clear
and agreement could be illegal either
because the statute specifically
prescribed the conduct
which was the agreement
subject or because courts had determined
that such agreements were opposed to
public policy and common example of the
ladder comes with contracts in restraint
of marriage.
If John Doe agrees to pay Richard Rowe
a thousand dollars in return for Richard
agreeing not to Mary Jane,
Courts will not enforce that agreement
even if the prohibition against
contractual restraints on marriage had,
has not been codified.
It though it has in many jurisdictions.
Traditionally,
courts will not order either party to
an illegal agreement to make any payment
to a another.
If a bargain was illegal under five 12
and both parties were in Perry dialect to
that is equally blameworthy section
five 98 provided that a party to that
agreement could quote neither
recover damages for breach thereof,
nor by rescinding the bargain and recover
the performance that he has rendered
they're under or its value unquote.
If you pay a scalper for a ticket when
the sale is prohibited by law courts
under the re first restatement standard
would normally not force the scalper to
give you your money back.
It seems unfair that people like the
scalper would come away with a windfall,
but the comment provided adjustive
justification for this effect, it's,
it's at further deterrence according
to the comment denying the plaintiff's.
In such cases,
recovery quote tends to diminish
the number of illegal agreements.
Ticket purchasers may be less
likely to pay for tickets.
If the law says the scalper can take the
money and run the no restitution rule
helps support the maxim of there
being no honor among thieves.
In fact,
while most of the formation defenses
try to police certain types of sharp
dealing illegality is a circumstance
where the law is trying to facilitate and
foster opportunism in order to
drive out illegal contracting.
There are limited exceptions to this
no restitution rule. Section 600,
uh,
provided an exception for s when there
was slight illegality where no law
prohibited the agreement
and there was no quote,
serious moral turpitude involved.
Uh,
these are circumstances where the equity
seem to Trump the strategic impulse to
deter illegal contracting.
The second restatement,
however,
has introduced a more flexible balancing
test on enforcability of illegal
agreements.
According to section one 78 of the
second restatement subsection one,
a promise or other term of agreement
is unenforceable on grounds of public
policy.
If legislation provides
that is unenforceable or the
interest in its enforcement
is clearly outweighed in the circumstances
by a public policy against the
enforcement of its terms.
Subjection to offers factors in the
interest of enforcing an agreement,
terms that which include the parties,
justified expectations,
any forfeiture that would result if the
enforcement were denied and any specific
public interest in enforcement.
Subsection three list factors
weighing against enforcement,
which include the strength of the public
policy and question as manifested by
legislation or judicial decisions.
The likelihood that failing to enforce a
term would further the public policy in
question,
the seriousness and deliberateness of
any misconduct involved and the nature of
the connection between the
misconduct and the terms in question.
Under the second restatement courts
have significantly more discretion to
determine whether to enforce
an agreement even if it, uh,
may violate public policy.
Let's look now at a case that
raises some of these questions.
Sign our versus Laroy,
which was decided by the Supreme Court
of Washington in 1954 sign are a grocery
store owner applied to the Washington
state liquor control board for a license
to sell beer. But his application
was denied. He and le I,
a friend of his agreed that he would
pay laroy $450 so that Laroy could get a
city official. Leroy new to
secure our sign are a license.
If this was unsuccessful,
the Roy would return the
$450 back to sign our sign.
Our did not get his license and the,
I did not return the bribe money.
The sign are sue to recover the funds
and at trial the Roy did not raise an
illegality defense and the trial court
found for sign are on appeal to the State
Supreme Court.
The Roy raise the defense of illegality.
And the first question before the court
was whether illegality as a procedural
matter could be raised for
the first time on appeal.
Usually parties are procedurally barred
from raising defenses on appeal that
we're not pled at the trial stage,
but the court held not only that Laurel,
I could raise it,
but also that the court could bring up
illegality on its own Sua sponte quote,
illegality if of a serious
nature need not be pleaded.
If it appears in the evidence,
the court of its own motion will
deny relief to the plaintiff.
The defendant cannot waive the
defense if he wishes to do so. Indeed,
if the court's suspects illegality,
it may examine witnesses and develop
facts not brought out by the parties and
thereby establish illegality that
precludes recovery by the plaintiff.
Why do you think that the court resolve
this issue where the court of its own
motion can raise the question and
decide the question of illegality?
Well,
probably it's because
illegality implicates the
public interest to a far greater
extent than other defenses that a
defendant might raise in a contractual
dispute.
The negative externalities of illegality
mean that courts shouldn't rely on
private incentives of the parties
to raise the, uh, the defense.
It was clear that there was in
fact illegality in this case.
So the next question became whether
that fact would bar the plaintiff from
recovery.
Not every instance of illegality the
court suggested would necessarily have the
result of barring a restitution.
If,
however,
the illegality is not serious and
neither public policy nor statute clearly
requires denial of relief.
Courts refuse to give effect to facts
showing illegality unless those facts are
essential to establish a prime aphasia
right of recovery or a pleaded by the
defendant. This however was not
such a case. According to the court,
the illegality at issue was of a serious
nature and concerned a matter which is
exclusively within the realm
of public policy. Further,
the evidence suggested that the parties
planned on using only illegal means,
presumably bribery of a city
official to accomplish their aims.
Therefore,
the court asserted it would not knowingly
aid in the furtherance of an illegal
transaction, but we'll leave
the parties where it finds them.
Think about this result Laroy ends up
$450 richer than he was before signing on
to this illegal agreement.
Given what we have discussed
from the restatements,
what do you think of the court's
reasoning is by not furthering an illegal
transaction,
the court hopes to deter such transactions
from being made in the first place.
This deterrence focused policy
reflects an ex ante efficiency concern,
or at least it's consistent with such
an ex ante concern at the expense of
expos.
Concerns about fairness.
This is a common tension in the law.
Think about which you find
more compelling in this case,
but by the way,
even from an ex ante perspective,
we'll this no restitution result really
reduced the number of illegal contracts.
If the rule is known, it should reduce
the willingness of bribers to bribe,
but it should also increase the
willingness of Bri bees to take bribes.
Imagine instead that we wanted to deter
employers from hiring undocumented
workers.
The no restitution rule would mean that
employers could hire and then refuse to
pay undocumented workers.
That might lead to more
employment of workers.
We might deter undocumented hiring more
by requiring employers to pay employees
three times what they promised.